now the 8 news now investigators looking
into a new Criminal courtroom in Las
Vegas Justice Court that's meant to
clean up the so-called Resort Corridor
now it all it also intends to get rid of
troublemakers some who get arrested over
and over again 8 news now investigator
Kyle Payne takes a hard look at how it
works
Mr Houston good morning maybe not such a
good morning for 61-year-old Rick
Houston seen here pleading guilty to a
trespass from December 18th of 2022 one
of dozens of arrests over the course of
his adult life multiple felony
convictions 38 arrests 19 citations six
failures to appear in court and many of
those crimes on or near the strip part
of the area here inside the yellow down
the strip in about a block on either
side that jail sentence will be
suspended that this judge in this
courtroom hoped to rid of repeat
offenders criminals like brick Houston
all the gray shaded areas are areas you
are not authorized to be in no I don't
think it's fear Fair he says would have
been getting banned only from the very
Casino where he pled guilty to
trespassing
but the whole strip is the whole point
so is this area just beyond this trip
where business owner Felix Arellano does
battle with the lunch crowd
and with the unwelcome crowd
this woman came in while the 8 news now
investigators were interviewing Ariana
about ongoing issues he faces with crime
and homelessness what's going on Daddy
especially from Sahara all the way to
downtown do you think if those people
got arrested and were banned from the
area that that would help improve your
business yes of course of course if it
were that easy the county wouldn't have
had to have allocated its resources to
fund a so-called Resort Corridor Court
stay out of the order out Corridor that
includes the entire uh Resort Corridor
up and down the Las Vegas Boulevard
on the Boulevard in the area near the
hotels and casinos police arrest tens of
thousands of criminals every year
any kind of violent crime you could
think of retired Metro Lieutenant Ted
Snodgrass oversaw Patrol in the valley
for over 33 years he even wrote his
master's thesis about crime on this trip
he says the millions of tourists who
come here for work and play are easy
victims it's the locals that come down
to Prey Upon the tourists that that have
changed and been more aggressive and so
it seems police and the courts are also
getting more aggressive but the judge
wouldn't speak with me on camera simply
refuse my request for an interview and
Las Vegas Metro they said they quote
will not be participating at this time
well we've warned them the party line
from the chairman of the Clark County
Commission who says this project has
been in the works since last spring it
takes a long time to establish a
specific Court to get it staffed up if
it involves an order outfit needs to be
here to that end judge saragosa's
courtroom is slowly getting up to speed
cases dismissed but in the three times
the eight news now investigators visited
there were glitches like when a
defendant is banned from the strip and
they're not in court to receive the
actual banned document we're still
figuring that part out and while they're
working it out did you receive a copy of
the criminal complaint this defendant
has to stay out of the strip appointing
the public defender's office to
represent you Ariana hunt was arrested
for committing a sex act inside a hotel
elevator and resisting arrest but she is
not about to defy the ban that would be
dummy you know to go back knowing that I
was um bad because it'd be trespassing
so I just stayed away
you don't want to get arrested again no
I'm scared I'm scared of Joe I don't
want to go but she will go back before
the judge for a preliminary hearing in
March much sooner than she'll be back on
the Strip Kyle Payne eight news now
the ACLU sued to stop Clark County from
Banning people from the strip saying
it's unconstitutional but the ACLU lost
that one